You want to have lunch together?
I'm exhausted.
Hamburgers are just the thing
when you're tired.
Why did she invite me?
Well, I guess it beats
agonizing over my art.
You eat a lot for someone so thin.
Really?
You need a lot of stamina to make art.
Girls studying art often eat a lot.
But the boys often have a small appetite.
I wonder why.
I thought you'd be more intimidating.
What?
People good at making art
often look intimidating.
I get you.
Those non-first timers are scary.
Right, so scary.
I'm relieved.
I thought it was just me.
Cutting out the canvas?
I don't understand.
I know it could be wild,
but oil painting is wackier
than I imagined.
But
that's also a way to mix things up.
Again, I almost let my thoughts stop
at a superficial level.